wenn Katar mal etwas nicht will was die
da auffahren wie viel Geld die
investieren wie viele Spione da am Werk
waren das ist schon unfassbar und auch
finde ich sehr unheimlich ist es nicht
auch sehr unheimlich dass das alles in
der Schweiz geschieht müssen wir nicht
auch mal darüber reden dass die Schweiz
selbst der Ort ist von dem dieses
Strukturen seit Jahrzehnten weitgehend
unbehelligt arbeiten
[Musik]
kann man diese WM mit gutem Gewissen
gucken also ich glaube die ehrliche
Antwort darauf ist nein aber man kann
sie mit schlechtem Gewissen gucken und
das werde ich so wie viele Millionen
vielleicht sogar Milliarden Menschen tun
und es ist eine Zumutung dass man uns
als Fußballfans als Fußball lieben in
einer Situation bringt in der wir uns
wirklich ethisch Gedanken machen müssen
ob es überhaupt vertretbar ist sich
diese WM als Fernsehzuschauer und du
Barbara schaffst du dir die Spiele an
ich finde warum hat es genau richtig
gesagt mit schlechten Gewissen gucken
ich weiß es nicht ob ich das gucke die
Frage ist ja wirklich nach einem Boykott
also sollte man gar nicht schauen und
ich finde auch man soll jetzt nicht den
einzelnen der das guckt irgendwie
Vorwurf machen aber für mich fühlt sich
so ein bisschen an wie eine tolle
Ausstellung angucken gehen die aus
Raubkunst besteht wo ich natürlich das
Ende daran dass diese Kunst ausgestellt
wird wenn ich in diese Ausstellung gehe
aber ich habe jetzt Gefühl das gibt es
in der Philosophie diese Idee der
moralischen Ansteckung dass man sich mit
einem eigentlich extrem um mit einer
unguten Geschichte in Verbindung bringt
und entweder sagt man sich dann das will
ich nicht ich will damit nichts zu tun
haben oder man sagt sich ich will es
halt trotzdem sehen aber ich habe ein
gutes Gefühl und in dieser Spannung bin
ich aber es gibt eine reale
Zusammenhänge also letztlich wenn wir es
schauen dann fließen wir Welt
der einzelne keine Macht hätte das gibt
es gibt ja immer diese Frage ist das
Problem eigentlich dass wir beitragen
dazu dass diese WM ein große Ereignis
ein Erfolg wird und das könnte man bei
Ausstellung aussagen wenn viele Tickets
verkauft werden dann wird diese
Ausstellung vielleicht weitergegeben und
so weiter und es gibt diese Frage der
moralischen Ansteckung und beim
beitragen ist es halt so jetzt wie in
der Schweiz z.B die können ja nicht
entscheiden mit den Gebühren sozusagen
tragen diese das ganze Programm mit wir
können ja nicht entscheiden was jetzt
ausgestrahlt indem wir es boykottieren
also natürlich ist eine tolle Quote eine
Bestätigung fürs Schweizer Fernsehen zum
Beispiel auch solche Spiele weiterhin zu
übertragen aber es ist alles so ein
bisschen schwierig wirklich von einem
Beitrag ich finde deine parallele mit
der Raumkunst die ist dies schlagend und
die meine Empfindungen bei der Sache
werden da gut adressiert weil eigentlich
ist es eine Form der Trauer und der
Traurigkeit dass seine Ereignis zu sein
eigenes der Freude der Völker
Verständigung der Feier der Freiheit als
leibliche Freiheit sein könnte unter
diesen Schatten unter diese
Beschwerden ist gestellt wird und es
gibt keine absurdere Vergabe an eine
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft als nach Katar
also Grönland wäre genauso plausibel
gewesen hat etwas genauso viele
einwohner hat etwa fußballkulturell
genauso viel zu sagen es ist ja ganz
viel Bestechung im Spiel gewesen und
auch alleine das so dass man eigentlich
den Eindruck hat das ist ein
unglaubliches Vorgehen was da ähm
geschehen ist und dass die FIFA das
mitgetragen hat oder was auch immer dass
sie damit drin hängt gibt einem auch so
ein gutes Gefühl gegenüber diesen Welt
Fußballverband wo ich wirklich die ganze
Zeit denke was ist denn das für ein
Laden und ist natürlich schade für Fans
die eigentlich gerne Fußball gucken
würden mit einem guten Gewissen aber ist
ja auch nichts Neues indem sie also man
weiß ja dass diese Vorwürfe gibt es
schon länger und so klar das ist ein
korrupter Verein ich glaube das kann man
so sagen aber wie kann es trotzdem dazu
kommen und und also ich meine der
schadet sich ja so arg die diese FIFA
mit dieser Vergabe und man kann sie
sagen Katha schadet sich weil jetzt das
Licht natürlich auf diese all diese
Missstände kommen das Stichworte
Ausbeutung und tote diese diese
Wanderarbeiter die sind in den
Bangladesch und so weiter kommen als man
spricht machen
genau in dieser Wüste wo eigentlich in
diesem Land das überhaupt gar keine
Fußballkultur hat ich glaube die haben
einen Stadium den Rest müssen sie bauen
das ist wirklich absurd wie du sagst
vielleicht könnten wir noch mal sehen es
gibt glaube ich drei Ebenen der
Problematisierung es gibt die Korruption
der Vergabe institutionell bei der FIFA
die ist indemisch gibt es seit
Jahrzehnten die trifft auch andere
Weltmeisterschaften in mehr oder weniger
starker Weise da kann man sagen dass es
traurig aber nicht spezifisch dann gibt
es einen menschenrechtsaspekt wo man
sagt es gibt in Katar sowohl was
Arbeitsrecht angeht als auch was
Minderheitenrechte Homosexuellen lgbtq
Bewegung da gibt es spezifische
Problemfelder da müsste man auch sagen
im Vergleich zu Russland beispielsweise
oder zu manch anderen vielleicht auch
nicht spezifisch und dann gibt es den
fußballkulturellen Aspekt dass man das
dieses Ereignis in ein Land gegeben hat
praktisch ohne Einwohner ohne
funktionierende Liga ohne Stadien in dem
dieses eigenes absolut nichts verloren
hat das also drei verschiedene Ebenen
ich würde sagen auf allen dreien das
hätte nicht geschehen dürfen aber ich
würde dieses diesen Eindruck nicht
teilen dass du sagst na ja das war
irgendwie in anderen vergaben auch so
oder auch diese Menschenrechtssituation
Katar ist schon noch mal ein anderer
Fall in vielerlei Hinsicht also diese
tausende von Totten die man zu beklagen
hat die da gearbeitet haben
manche sagen 6000 manche sagen 3 5000 es
hat auch ganz schwer letztlich die
qualifizieren keine Parallele denke ich
und es gibt auch keine Parallele da hat
gerade der
investigativdesk von SRF jetzt noch
einmal nachgelegt mit einer groß
angelegten Reportage es gibt keine
andere Vergabe die so begleitet war von
Spionage von Bestechung und so weiter
und das Problem war ja das selbst sehr
Blatter glaube ich 2011 gesagt habe man
könnte Katar diese Vergabe auch wieder
wegnehmen was Katana natürlich in
Alarmbereitschaft versetzt hat weswegen
ist dann dieses Spionage gab um diese
diese WM behalten zu können das gab es
noch nie vorher also insofern finde ich
dieses naja das war vorher ja auch schon
so finde ich so ein bisschen schwierig
ich meine sie sagt die teuerste WM aller
Zeiten das hat wahrscheinlich die damit
zu tun das ist die neueste ist das geht
wahrscheinlich immer immer genau diese
diese Beträge das wird ja gesagt das hat
auch ein Potenzial also man spricht von
diesem Sports washing also dass ein Land
Propaganda macht und sich gut darstellt
mit Hilfe des Sports aber ich habe den
Eindruck ist umgekehrt derzeit also die
Missstände was wussten wir davor über
Qatar sehr wenig jetzt wissen wir was da
alles schief läuft der Schuss geht total
hinten raus möglicherweise ja genau
möglicherweise vielleicht ist es
trotzdem ein Anlass oder ein Druck von
außen der das Land dazu bringt ein
bisschen besser zu werden in Sachen
Menschenrechte also das wissen wir jetzt
ja noch nicht das ist ein bisschen FIFA
Ideologie es ist ja eine Abwandlung des
Arguments Handel und Wandel dass man
dadurch dass man mit Leuten interagiert
auch deren Werte ändert aber gesehen
normal politisch funktioniert bisher
nicht so gut in Russland nicht und in
China aber natürlich könnte man sagen
einerseits ist der Fokus jetzt auf den
Problemen in Katar andererseits hat sich
Katar auch im Vergleich zu anderen
Ländern der Region natürlich in gewisser
Weise bemüht es gibt da
transformationsveränderungen und
vielleicht kann man sich mal und das ist
was kontrovers aber ich will es trotzdem
sagen man hat das Gefühl es hat auch ein
bisschen ein leicht Anti muslimisches
anti-arabisches Element dass man
irgendwie das Gefühl hat dort werden
Missstände die es in Russland lgbtq auch
gab dies in Brasilien da verrotten die
Stadien das war finanziell eine
Katastrophe auch gab die werden in
besonderer Weise hochgetrieben und als
ob es im Hintergrund unserer Kultur
etwas gebe wo man sagt daran Katar da
finden wir es besonders
Vorwurf das ist ja wirklich so eine rote
Karte sehr vorsichtig vorgehen ich finde
wirklich Rassismusvorwürfe die sind so
Totschlagargumente und kein Mensch will
irgendwie
da dann irgendwie sagen nur sie kein
Problem und so ich finde es ein bisschen
heikel Vorwurf weil man muss finde ich
schon ganz klar sehen es ist eine andere
Situation im katalys waren Brasilien und
es war in Russland schon alleine
deswegen was du gesagt hast dass es
natürlich im landest wo man überhaupt
keine Fußball WM erwartet das ist anders
in Russland das ist sowieso anders in
Brasilien zum Beispiel die ganze
Klimafrage also das ist ein so heißes
Land man geht davon aus dass 2017 Katar
unbewohnbar sein wird weil heiß und da
baut man diese Stadien hin wir müssen
uns übrigens noch tabene während
Adventszeit haben wir jetzt eine WM weil
es sonst zu heiß gewesen wäre es ist
alles eigentlich
meine Karte zeigen weil das ist eine
extrem eurozentrische westliche
Perspektive seit 60 Jahren finden diese
Weltmeisterschaften für die Südhalbkugel
im Winter statt niemand hat sich darüber
beklagt dass wir Brasilien Argentinien
Südafrika die Dinge eigentlich im Winter
stattfinden und jetzt auf einmal fangen
die Europäer an rum zu pinzen weil wir
sind da auch nicht vielen Dank das ist
keine Argument aber ich finde die Frage
des Paul chords stellt sich z.B noch
ganz anders bezüglich der Frage was
machen eigentlich die Vertreter und
Vertreterinnen der offiziellen
Regierungen also ob wir jetzt diese
matschis gucken oder nicht ist das eine
ob die diplomatischen Beziehungen weiter
bestehen sollen und man dahin reist um
diesen Sports washing Vorschub zu
leisten ist eine andere Frage ich weiß
nicht wer dazu steht diplomatischer
finde ich angemessen in diesen diesen
Sachen das würde ich sagen also das ist
ein Statement eindeutiges Statement und
da muss man nicht hin jetzt hat das eine
ganze Fußballmannschaft da nicht hingeht
wie eine andere Geschichte aber das
führende Politikerin da nicht hingehen
das fände ich jetzt richtig und das
steht ja auch das stand jetzt
interessanterweise praktisch nicht zur
Diskussion alleine norwegen hat man
ernsthaft diskutiert ob man diese WM
boykottieren würde als Mannschaft das
heißt nicht hinfahren würde ansonsten
haben die Verbände Möglichkeiten
gefunden durch Symbole durch Aktionen
auch durch Spendengelder auf die
Probleme hinzuweisen und zu sagen wir
fahren hin wir haben uns diese WM nicht
ausgesucht wir wünschen sie wären
woanders das ist die Position des DFB
aber wir fahren natürlich hin wenn sie
dort schaffen und versuchen mit den
Möglichkeiten die wir haben dort Akzente
zu setzen und politisch ist es so
beispielsweise die deutsche
Innenministerin die fährt jetzt zum
Auftaktspiel der deutschen Mannschaft
hat sich aber zu sichern lassen
offiziell vom Emir das egal wen man
liebt egal wie man lebt dass alle Fans
dort willkommen sind und sicher dort so
leben können wie Sie wollen das heißt
symbolpolitisch hat sie einen zugestellt
ist abgewonnen als Bedingung dafür dass
sie kommt das sind so kleine
diplomatische Mini mikrodynamiken die
schon etwas bewirken können in einem
Land und das sieht man doch daran auch
gleich wieder schon alleine dass das
diskutiert wird dass es nicht stimmt zu
sagen das ist ein anti-muslimischer
Reflex weil alle diese Maßnahmen wurden
nicht getroffen bezüglich Brasilien oder
oder Russlands da hatte man nicht diese
Diskussionen wo man irgendwie solche
Ideen da propagieren soll oder verlangen
soll naja also die lgbtq-lage in
Russland war vor vier oder sechs Jahren
nicht besser als heute vielleicht auch
mit irgendwelchen fahren da rein
marschieren das ist auch mehr und mehr
gekommen nur dass man pauli z.B in
Hamburg die haben ja ähm die glaube ich
die Regenbogenflagge auch auf ihrem Jako
oder irgendwas es gibt ja immer mehr
solche Clubs nicht so ein Fan von dieser
Symbol Politik ehrlich gesagt also ich
finde irgendwie sind am besten auch wie
man das nennt dass man sondern durch
falsche rein oberflächliche Zeichen sich
mit Gruppen solidarisiert weil es sich
marketingmäßig gut macht ohne ein
wirklich tieferes und
am besten ist ja ganz gut darin das sagt
auch die sagt nach die anderen
Perspektiven sozusagen falsch zu
verhandeln und richtig zu reden und
alles irgendwie schön zu färben zu reden
aber dann einfach geopolitisch dazu
dahin zu gehen oder das Geld fließen nur
das Öl fließt und so also irgendwie
finde ich schon wir müssten was tun es
ist schwierig für mich ich finde das
alles sehr schlimm aber relational in
dieser Region ist Katar sicher noch ein
Land von dem man sagen kann das ist
relativ stabil es ist auf einem relativ
guten Weg es hat progressive Elemente
und der Pitch am Anfang war ja auch von
vielen Menschen gegeben es nach Katar
für die gesamte Region als ein
entwicklungsheim ob das wirklich eine
aussichtsreiche Sache ist das würde ich
trotzdem bezweifeln ja und ob das
wirklich der Grund war deswegen vergeben
hat nein ja und ich weiß auch nicht mit
diesem guten Weg sein also noch dieser
Dokumentation von SRF von dem
investigativ Test wo man noch einmal
sieht was es heißt wenn Katar mal etwas
nicht will was die da auffahren wie viel
Welt die investieren wie viele Spione da
am Werk waren das ist schon unfassbar
und auch finde ich sehr unheimlich ist
es nicht auch sehr unheimlich dass das
alles in der Schweiz geschieht müssen
wir nicht auch mal darüber reden dass
die Schweiz selbst der Ort ist von dem
dieses Strukturen seit Jahrzehnten
weitgehend unbehelligt Arbeiten ich
fahre mit meinen Kindern immer in den
Zoo die FIFA ist ja da oben du kannst
eigentlich fast schon rein spazieren es
ist wirklich so aber gut ich meine über
die Schweiz könnten wir eine eigene
Sendung machen und das sieht man ja auch
wiederum Zusammenhang zwischen
Weltfußball und Geld warum ist das ganze
in der Schweiz das sind natürlich alles
Fragen die unbequem sind und die in der
Schweiz auch glaube ich sehr viel mehr
Aufmerksamkeit es ist traurig dass wir
ein so schönes Ereignis mit so viel
schwierigen ethischen Bedenken belasten
müssen nicht wahr du bist wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen trauriger wie ich weil du
gerne Fußball guckst ich hätte das gerne
als wirklich schönes Freudenfest gehabt
das wird es nicht
Kommentator